[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show my guest
today is russ roberts i've wanted to
have russ on the show for a very long
time indeed russ roberts is the
president of shalem college in jerusalem
and the john and gene denault research
fellow at stanford university's hoover
institution roberts is interested in
making complicated ideas understandable
he founded and hosts the award-winning
weekly podcast econ talk one of my
favorites conversations for the curious
with more than 800 episodes available in
the archives which i believe began in
2006
back in the pleiasian era one of the
pioneers past guests include christopher
hitchens martha nussbaum michael lewis
angela duckworth and naseem nicholas
taleb among many others his two rap
videos believe it or not on the ideas of
john maynard keynes and f a hayek have
more than 13 million views on youtube i
highly recommend both i just watched
them again
i would say an hour ago just prior to
getting warmed up for this conversation
his latest book wild problems a guide to
the decisions that define us explores
the challenges of using rationality when
facing big life decisions he's also the
author of gambling with other people's
money how adam smith can change your
life the price of everything the
invisible heart and the choice you can
find all things russ roberts roberts dot
info and on twitter you can find him at
econtalker
russ welcome to the show
great to be here tim
i thought we would begin
with
perhaps an oblique entry point and that
is a post you wrote
which was a eulogy for your father and
i'd like to read just a bit of it
if if i could do that and it's not going
to take terribly long but here goes
i sometimes think that my dad really
could have been a minor american poet or
a more renowned story writer if he'd
spent less time with his children and
grandchildren the trade-off was easy for
him he chose us he had many talents
being a father was the talent he chose
to cultivate that's one of the lines i'm
going to come back to all of us who
survive him his good wife his children
and his grandchildren are so lucky that
we had him for so long so if you want to
honor my father's memory spend more time
with your children or your parents or
those you love for dad quality time
demanded quantity time that's the second
line i'll come back to it's harder than
it seems so many things more tangible
more alluring with more immediate
returns call for our attention and
distract us
i was hoping you could just expand a bit
on what it looked like
what it meant for your father to choose
being a father as the talent he wanted
to cultivate and then the quality time
demanded quantity time as i think about
kids i don't have any yet this is of
interest to me
and my dad died two years ago roughly
was 89 years old
born in 1930
i actually would start with the
point about distraction because i think
it's
about more than parroting
life goes
by so quickly
and we let it
and somebody pointed out uh might have
been ryan holiday i think you know you
um
when you're on your deathbed what would
you give for
one more day
with someone you love one more
ice cream cone one more sunset it's
really trite but it's not tried at all
actually it's incredibly essential to a
life well lived and you know there's a
beautiful song about it called may i
suggest which i recommend
profoundly as a encouragement to pay
attention
and so we
we often don't you know
we miss the sunset or we see it and we
just we're too busy texting or we ate
the ice cream cone and we're talking
while we're eating it we're hardly
noticing it's going down it's compulsive
and i think
parenting
but more than parenting life
requires uh paying attention and um
you know my dad i would say my dad was
one of the least meditative people
who was born in 1930 there weren't that
many of them to be honest it's a it's a
more uh recent phenomenon but my dad
had zero i went on three silent
meditation retreats while he was alive
and he found that utterly bewildering
so he was not a meditator
but he understood somehow that principle
about
paying attention to what's important and
what was important to him was us
his children and his wife and his family
and
as i said he used to complain he said
he said it's terrible he said god gave
me such a big soul
and so little talent i have so much to
say
and i can't say it he wanted to be a
poet he wrote lots of poems many of them
pretty good he liked a few of them and
his joke really was you read the line
but the joke was
you know he'd like to be a minor
american probably he didn't want to be
robert frost or edison vince malay
he had been happy to be a quieter person
with a couple good poems and he might
have achieved that if he had devoted
himself to that craft but he instead
devoted himself to us
one of my favorite things about my dad
when we had our kids and i'd say dad you
want to read a story you want to read a
book to want to you know one of my kids
he was so disdainful of that the idea of
reading a book that someone else had
written
was so cheating to him
all of his stories were made up he
he told us
hundreds of stories of my children
hundreds of stories that he crafted that
he made up and he could have been you
know a great children's writer he could
have been
maybe a minor american poet but uh he
spent most of his time with us his free
time
and does the quality time demanded
quantity time just
is that akin to to come up with a few
good ideas you have to come up with a
lot of bad ideas you just have to throw
a lot against the wall what does that
what does that mean
i think for those of us who are
ambitious who have big egos which
is sometimes me
maybe you i don't know i'm sure it's
also me
right
you can
comfort yourself and i think sometimes
fill yourself into saying
well you know i don't give
friend x
family member y
situation z the trip to the hospital the
going to the funeral i don't do those
things because you know those take too
much time i got i have more important
things to do but when i am with them
it's quality time i really give them
myself and i think what my dad believed
and i believed or tried to believe as a
parent
for my four kids is that
quality time requires quantity time you
can't just turn it on you can't just say
okay let's have a serious conversation
go
it doesn't work that way
and we understand that about friendship
most of our friendships
take years
where we
experience things together
do things together have
intense conversations
and the nth one the last one the next
one
is building on all of that and the idea
they can just say okay i'm here for you
and which is i think the the modern
impulse and it's good it's not bad it's
good to be here for people
but i think the quantity time part of it
helps us cultivate that quality time get
the hang of it and it's certainly i
think
i don't know if you ever spend a long
time with somebody on a lazy afternoon
it's just a different experience
yeah
thank you
for providing that context and we're
going to bounce around as is my want
so i thought we would we would flash
forward now to the other
side of the bookshelf to the book end
that is present day what does shalem
mean
if anything
a year ago almost to the day i i took
the job as president of shalom college
which is here in jerusalem
which in hebrew is illusion and
jerusalem if you look at the
anglicization of yugoslavia the end of
jerusalem is s-a-l-e-m which is salem in
massachusetts and lots of other places
those cities are named for jerusalem
and
the name of jerusalem has that root that
s l m the three-letter root in hebrew
which typically is translated as peace
shalom is the same root
but shalem which slightly different
it's a reference to the fact that we're
in jerusalem
but it's also a reference to the to the
meaning of that word which is
complete
well-rounded and so our students
we hope
will emerge from their experience here
more complete now they're not fully
complete you can't really be shalom it's
an aspiration
but i think it's a great aspiration for
all of us and certainly when you embark
on an educational experience
you know it's become very fashionable
in in modern times to see college as a
professional career pre-professional
experience prepare you for
accounting engineering computer science
and so on and that's nice nothing wrong
with that but shalom chile we think it's
something more than that
we believe it's about the cultivation of
certain habits of mind and heart that
make you a full human being and not just
a successful
person in the marketplace they're not
unrelated
i think we're going to certainly
in some ways circle back to that with i
think the the meat and potatoes of this
conversation which is going to focus on
a lot of topics in the new book
but i want to provide a little more
connective tissue for folks who may not
be familiar with you
so i'd like to
take a second to quote from an interview
you did with tyler cowan who is
another one of my favorite interviewers
along with yourself
so it's quite the dynamic duo to have
you both in one place and from the
transcript so this is from tyler
as a hayekian how can we do science
better and then your response is i think
that's a trick question hayek of course
was concerned with scientism the
illusion that what we're doing was
scientific i'm a big fan of the pretense
of knowledge his nobel prize acceptance
speech so i want to pause here for a
second because i'm going to admit
something very embarrassing which is i
had no idea
who fa hayek was prior to your rap
videos and i suppose that hopefully
counts as a huge success in terms of the
rap videos reaching people who
maybe can't find their ass with both
hands when it comes to economics and
economic theory but
could you please just give people
a brief description of what it means to
be a hayek and you can do this however
it makes sense and then also
perhaps unpack a bit the pretense of
knowledge
this speech and why
you like it
what do we have two three hours
yeah we have two or three hours exactly
it's actually one of the goals of that
rap video the first one and then this we
did two i did them with uh filmmaker
uh john papolo
part of the goal of those videos
actually was to try to capture some
serious economic ideas that we try to
make it entertaining obviously which is
why we put in a rap format
but part of the goal is just to let
people know
that this
person existed because he's not well
known and one of the common
comments we got on youtube was uh who is
this guy how come i ever heard of him so
you're not alone you're a very good
company he's not part of the kayak is
not part of the standard curriculum of
economics departments forget
everyday learning or reading
he's not the greatest writer he's not
the most entertaining writer if you're
going to start with something
actually the pretext of knowledge is one
of his most accessible
pieces it's ironic it was his nobel
prize speech but it's not a highfalutin
highbrow technical greek letter
kind of economics treatise it's a very
readable essay on
i think a major challenge of modern life
that when he wrote it and when he
delivered it it was sort of interesting
and now it's more tragic because it's
become a central question
to me of of modern life so we have
on one side we have the so-called
rationalists
who believe in evidence-based data
science
and i love all those things so did hayek
they're all really good
the problem is is that sometimes there's
what he called scientism scientism
the something that has the look of
science that looks scientific and it
fools people into thinking they
understand something when in fact they
don't and i think you know that it's
trivial
all right when i say it it's going to be
so obvious there are two kind of
mistakes there's two kinds of ignorance
there's the things we don't know
and that they're the things we think we
know that aren't true
the things we know that we don't know
that we wish we understood we wish we
had access to the truth the things we
think we've discovered is true that in
fact are not
and that was the focus of that piece and
in fact
that piece was it's kind of
for maybe
15 seconds of inside baseball he was an
intellectual antagonist of john maynard
keynes in the 1930s in london
and he lost
cain's beat the
beat him keynes won he won the
intellectual
battle he won the battle of the
marketplace of ideas he triumphed and
pike tried to take him on in his own
terms and can speed him meaning tried to
build a model of the economy that would
be like keynes but better
kane says itself kane's model itself is
kind of really hard to understand and
anybody's taken undergraduate
macroeconomics gets a sort of
bastardized version of it that
whatever cain's not the clearest writer
either but he's a much more entertaining
writer flash forward to hayek's nobel
prize in the 70s i want to say 74. what
he does is he says
you know i tried to build a model of the
economy that would be like a big
engineering machine that i could
manipulate or understand
which levers led to which
flows of this or that and he said that
was a fool's game that's what he's
saying when in that nobel prize speech
he's saying
i can't explain that
no one can he uses the example the
analogy of a sports event it's like a
football game he says
imagine that you could have all the data
on everything you could possibly measure
about all the players
whether they slept well
how much they ate the night before or
they're having a fight with their with
their wife
how their how their game last week was
and the injury they sustained and
whether they're fully over it or only
partially over it is it even then i mean
there's just no way you're going to
predict the outcome of the game you
might be able to get close
you might get on average right maybe
but it's not predictable the way the
location of saturn is
on july 17 2027
they're really good we're really good at
that
you know what we're not good at the
value of bitcoin on july 20 17 2027 or
interest rates on july 17 2027 or
whether it's going to be a crash or
whether there's going to be a recession
and economics what people want of us is
well tell me what it's going to be like
tomorrow professor
i need to know
and the professor should say i have no
idea but my best guess is it's going to
be like yesterday
but it often isn't and if you don't tell
people that you're indulging in
scientism because what you've done
in that case for example is you've taken
the data from the past and you've
extrapolated to the future and yes
sometimes the future is somewhat like
the past except for when it isn't and
then it smacks you in the face so what
hayek was warning us against there which
is there's an irony is
given the current moment we're in
what he's warning against there is the
authority of experts using the tools of
science
to mislead
and how easy it is to be misled so it's
a profound piece and i recommend it you
found another web it's available
easy to read for a non-economist
we'll include that in the show notes for
everybody to
peruse i wanted to ask you another
question about
mr friedrich a hayek and that is
actually the explanation of a quote so
this this quote i saw pop up numerous
places when i was doing some reading on
mr hayek and it's from the fatal
conceit and the quote is as follows
speaking as someone who really wouldn't
claim to understand even the
fundamentals of economics which again
embarrassed to say but the quote is you
probably can see this coming
quote the curious task of economics is
to demonstrate to men how little they
really know about what they imagine they
can design
could you explain what he means by that
yeah that book by the way
i think it's 108 pages at least in some
editions i used to give it away to
people as a gift
more like a punishment it turned out
they don't want to read it it's dense
it's very dense but i do recommend it if
you're brave soul you could wait do some
waiting it's very murky water at times
as i said he's not the most felicitous
phrase maker but anyway that's that
particular sentence it's pretty
convoluted right but it is saying
something profound
which is the following
economists especially
in the last 10 15 years see themselves
as social engineers
and as if they can tweak and tinker and
move people around
adam smith
about 200 years before that quote
said something similar he said he said
the man of system
meaning a person who has a a theory
about how the world works she could
think about marx or lenin or
or uh mount seiton
they move the human beings in their
country around
like the pieces of a chess board
ignoring the fact that they have a
motion of their own
it's just a profound metaphor for
thinking about how to bring about social
change so what hayek is saying there is
that economics the task the curious task
of economics because kind of strange by
the curious event peculiar the curious
task of economics is to tell people that
what they think they can design
is often not going to work out so it's
really a fancy
convoluted way of saying
you should beware the law of unintended
consequences and uh that is one of the
great
virtues of studying economics or can be
is to appreciate that and by the way tim
i gotta if i can go back yes please i
never got to tell you what a hayekian is
oh yes we talked about the pretense of
knowledge but the other key part of it
is understanding that the world often
emerges from the bottom up and not just
from the top down and that many things
that are orderly that we see around us
are not designed by anyone but rather
emerge from the individual choices we
make
a simple example would be we go to a
restaurant and it's really noisy i can't
hear you you're sitting next to me
and i'm thinking why is it so loud in
here
well let's just turn down the bot
where's that switch oh there no there is
no switch and if you if somebody stands
up hey everybody it's too loud in here
let's all talk quietly and we'll be fine
but what happens is we all kind of
start ratcheting it up and similarly
with traffic
like who sent out the memo that says
between 5 a.m and 7 a.m in the morning
go really slow
that's not my intention not your
intention next to me in the car one one
lane over and yet here we are is if
we've been commanded from the top down
so if you were we all understand that's
the way traffic the traffic doesn't work
that way it's not designed by anyone but
there are many things in life where you
think okay i gotta blame someone who is
it
who did this and the answer is we did
sometimes and that's a deep insight of
hayek also
so i think maybe for another
conversation or if we have time at the
end of this one i would love to ask you
again as a complete
neophyte
how
hayek
would think of setting initial
conditions if he would think of that at
all say contrasted with keynes which i
thought of
prompted by these two rap videos which i
should say you can you have
some incredible
actors performers for
and uh i really do recommend people
check them out and i will link to them
in the show notes so maybe we'll come
back to that but let's hop
directly into
wild problems a guide to the decisions
that define us and the easiest place to
start is with the question of why why
write this book we all have finite time
and
you could you could spend your time in
any number of ways new rap videos poetry
you're very cross-disciplinary i want to
say also very playful with the he wasn't
a felicitous phrase maker
very much like that
why write wild problems
well i start the book off with a story
of a friend of mine who's trying to
decide whether to have he and his wife
are trying to somewhere to have a kid
and he tells me
about it he says well we made a list of
the costs and benefits and we still
could make a decision
and i thought well that's interesting
through most of human history
people didn't make a list of cost
benefits to decide
whether to have children they just had
them either because they couldn't stop
them or they thought it was a good idea
and they didn't spend a lot of time
thinking about whether it was a good
idea or not and the implication of a
cost-benefit analysis is that
i look at my life now without kids and i
look at my life with kids and which is
going to be
better and i put better in quotes
and what the real question is what does
that mean
and one way to think about it which is
very reasonable is more fun
right having kids
we all know what the costs are
you know there's diapers to be changed
and there's
errands to take them on and school to
drive them to and
little league games to watch or whatever
it is music lessons
they're pretty helpless early on only
for the first 18 years or so
so they're a lot responsibility and i
think if you're looking from the outside
having children it looks like a not the
best deal
uh you know a joke of the book oh hey
get to get a minivan that's exciting so
why do people do it and if you look at
it narrowly
as a cost-benefit decision meaning more
fun
mostly would say it's not more fun in
fact i think most parents would say it's
not necessarily more fun
it's not like
every day
with kids is a day at the beach
and even the days at the beach often
they're cranky and
crying they need something
so why do people have kids is it
irrational and i think most of us
understand that
at least somewhere in the back of our
mind that
we have children not because it's more
fun or not because
the average day with children will be
better than the average day without or
that there'll be more good days than bad
days
and i would add this is true of marriage
even it's not just having a child
parenting a child it's
should just tie yourself to a spouse
right it's a tough question most people
if you look at it from the outside
you know i don't know about you but i
look at other married couples they don't
look that happy
some of them do but it's not like it's
necessarily the obvious outcome
and so
what i suggested to my friend and what
the reason i wrote the book is that
i think there's more to life than fun
obviously and
the sources that make our life deeply
meaningful and purposeful
are not just the day-to-day things there
are overarching senses of who we are
and and how we see ourselves
and
the meaning and purpose we have in life
that are
ultimately more important in these kinds
of decisions and these kinds of
decisions which are whether to get
married whether they have kids how many
kids to have whether to move to israel
whether to take a new job whether to
study
something crazy at college
those decisions are not amenable to data
so this brings us back to hayek in my
view
they're not amenable to data so the
standard algorithms and evidence that we
use to be quote rational are not so
helpful in this framework and so i
thought i wrote the book to help people
think about how to think about that
do you think your younger self
would have agreed that those things are
not amenable to data let's just if we if
we dial back
the chronology
15 20 years or do you think he would
have also agreed with that
you're really kind tim we're gonna have
to dial it back about 40 years
[Laughter]
i joke in the book that when i was in
graduate school at the university of
chicago
there was a
literally carved in stone a corrupted
quote more or less right from lord
kelvin that says if it cannot be
measured your knowledge is meagre and
unsatisfactory
and uh
that's the way i was raised
intellectually in graduate school you
know we went out and did empirical work
meaning we looked at the world
we had a theory we tested it
we tested it with data with real world
evidence and then we decided whether the
theory was right or not and i was very
convinced when i was younger that those
models of of economic behavior and
non-economic behavior but using the
tools of economics were very powerful i
still think economics is pretty powerful
but i don't think i ever thought that
necessarily they were those kind of
models were good for making personal
decisions
i think what's been fascinating about
the last 20 years of the internet
and the smartphone is that
the answers are always here right yeah
whether it's somebody's batting average
or the capital of an obscure country
or something much more interesting like
where should i have dinner tonight or
what movie am i going to like or what
book would i like if i like this book
that's a fantastic improvement in the
quality of life right in the old days
you go to the little bookstore they have
17 books this old crotchety guy behind
the counter would say
hey you like hemingway oh you might like
fitzgerald and that was nice and those
people were often fabulous repositories
of wisdom and suggestions
but amazon is better
it sounds a lot better
and the temptation is to take
that improvement of day-to-day life into
the rest of our life
and i think most of us realize you can
but it's really an unpleasant discovery
because if i can use ways
to get from a to b
where's the app that tells me whether i
should go to b in the first place oh
there isn't one actually well that's not
fun and so what i try to do in the book
is to remind you that you can't use an
app for that there isn't one
and how to think about
those choices in life of where to go how
to spend your days whether you should
marry whether you should have kids and
so on
let's rewind and look at some historical
examples if you're open to it because i
have of course notes in front of me
copious notes we won't get through all
of them
but i'll just use a q and we can we can
hop from there
charles darwin
would you like to tell us any stories
about charles darwin
yeah
so he's 29 years old he's thinking you
know maybe i should get married he's
been uh
he's been out on the beagle you know
he's
he's really on a great career trajectory
and
he's on the path to be
arguably
if not the greatest maybe one of the two
or three greatest scientists of all time
and he thinks you know maybe i'm missing
something so he makes a pro con plus
minus cost benefit list of marriage
it's a really embarrassing list it's so
bad it's um
so you can find this i imagine you can
find it online oh yeah you can find out
it is handwriting we have his actual
journal entry in england you go to
london i don't know if you can see it or
not but it's reproduced online all over
the place many people have noticed this
this great moment of
scientific inquiry in the part of darwin
is it a good idea to get married so he
makes this list
and what i noticed which i i i've seen
the list a number of times when i was in
the past
but what i noticed for the first time
when i was writing this book is that
he has no idea what marriage is like
he doesn't have enough data which is
reasonable when you think about it
because he's never been married he has
some married friends presumably he
watches them after dinner talking
or before dinner or during dinner but
that's it he has no access
to the inner life of marriage or theater
life of a parent which is also worried
about whether he's gonna have kids and
if you look at his list it's
overwhelmingly that marriage and
children are a horrible idea
he talks about how
he's gonna have to maybe leave london
because she won't like london he talks
about his kids might get sick he talks
and then it would bother him and depress
him he talks about how expensive they
might be he talks about having to visit
her relatives and of course in the back
of his mind reasonably
is that he is going to be
one of the greatest scientists of all
time and that's a lot to give up for
what he actually calls the benefits
my favorite being female chit-chat
and then better than a dog anyway
which is really not not the greatest
endorsement of married life or the
opposite sex or
awkward
so darwin makes this list and if you
write it down as i do i organize it a
little bit differently than he wrote it
down and you look at the pluses are
getting married and the negatives
getting the negatives are bigger more
numerous so what does he do gets married
he says
it's a journal entry he comes back to it
and he writes
he has this incredible stream of
consciousness paragraph where he says oh
my gosh i'm going to be all by myself
i'm going to become this weird guy in a
dingy apartment and ah mary mary mary
qed he says
qed meaning what was to be proven has
been proven demonstrated quotas
demostratum and this is bizarre first of
all it's bizarre that's a little
scientism right because it's not
anything close to it you know qeqid qed
qvd is what you put at the end of a
mathematical proof right this is not a
mathematical proof this is the most
unmathematical
attempt at making a decision and of
course a show
he's not the only one many great
rational scientific analytical
people even specialists decision making
have trouble making decisions
because
these kind of decisions at least are not
easily done with a rational framework
and so i think that's
liberating it tells you those are you
listening and going through these life
decisions and i'll tell you tim book
comes out
on august 9th
and i've already had people write me and
say can you get me a copy now i'll pay
for it
because i have a decision to make i have
a decision to make and i'm really
anxious about it
and i tell them two things when i say
well it's not that kind of book exactly
it's not gonna it's not an algorithm i
could tell you how to make the decision
exactly it's really gonna help you think
about how to make a decision not what
the right decision is two different
things
it's going to help you organize your
thinking about it and realize that your
normal thinking which is this cost
benefit plus minus thing might lead you
astray
i would love to double click on
that description
to maybe
examine the
choice of spouse
situation that many people will find
themselves in let's
presuppose that they want a life partner
to build a family with in some capacity
that's been decided
but then there's the question of
who
uh and i would love to know what advice
you might give someone who is trying to
sort through that or how they might
think about it
how they might structure their thinking
what advice would you
potentially give to such a person
in the book i talked about that choice
and i
kind of tongue-in-cheek talk about
penelope from the odyssey ulysses wife
who's waiting for his return from the
trojan war
and um
it's a i mean it's such a great moment
in literature
she's got 108 suitors
living large in her in her
house
waiting trying to wear her down and get
her to pick one of them
because they don't think he's coming
back and either she does she's hoping he
will or doesn't really want to remarry
but it's awkward 108 guys in your house
our son's there
not not not the best situation he's you
know being a little bit inadequate i
suspect telemachus
and i show that there's actually kind of
there's a mathematical formula you could
use a famous mathematical problem it's
really beautiful elegant thing
of
how she could maximize the odds of
finding the best
partner
and
it's great you go out with a few of them
and the presumption of the problem is
that once you've said no to someone you
can't get it back just a little bit like
life there's some exceptions to that but
in general once it doesn't work out they
move on you move on
so
you go out with the first turns out
about 37 of them mathematically 37 and
you rank them
and you take the best one of the first
37 and you use them as a benchmark and
of course we kind of all did this right
we got with a bunch of people and then
you look back on the ones and you think
well whoever i do marries got to be
better than the
ones that i turned down
and so what she should do if she wants
the best one
is that after that 37th
she should pick the first one she finds
is better than the best of the first 37.
you think well that's kind of cool in
fact the odds that she finds the best
one is actually about 37
which turns out not to be a coincidence
put that to the side not so interesting
but that's pretty amazing if i said to
you you've got to find the best
person in this group of 108 people
what's the best strategy
that's the best strategy but of course
when you start to think about it it's
not a good strategy to try to find the
best person because for a lot of reasons
one of which is
how do i stop at 108
208 i could do even better 2008
20 000 today of course many people date
lots of different people and never
settle down that's okay maybe they
choose to but some of them are just
saying i haven't found the right one yet
and so what i argue in there is that
best i mean alain de baton has a
wonderful youtube video i recommend on
that's i think the title is you're going
to marry the wrong person fantastic
short video
yeah don't show it to my wife because
she thinks she married the right person
i don't want her to see it and depress
her but seriously
there's no best
and part of the theme of my book is that
most of life is a matrix
by that i don't mean like the movie the
red or blue pill what i mean is that
it's a set of complicated attributes
that are pluses and minuses for all
kinds of things so
the person you're with
that you're seeing now whoever's listed
out there you know there's a certain
level of attractiveness a certain level
of sweet kindness or a certain level of
intelligence or a certain level many
many many attributes and then there's
chemistry and
sexual attraction got all those things
working
and so which is the best one oh well
i need a formula to add up all those
measurements so i can get a single
number and then i'll just pick the one
that gets the best score
and i'd argue that's the wrong way to
think about life it's the wrong way to
think about how to pick your friends
it's the wrong way to think about how to
find the best job it's the wrong way to
think about most things and it's not
just because you can't find the best one
it's it's not even well defined
and i think that's
helpful again
it doesn't make it easy to still pick
the one you're gonna marry but you know
i said i give a short list of but pick
somebody you respect who introduced
company to joy you can talk to forever
you can share your secrets with
you have some chemistry
that's great that's so hard to find bury
him ask him they probably won't marry
you but at least ask him
what would you say is is there an
associated feeling for you and this may
be getting too far from the kind of shut
up and compute
the congressional physicalist
side of things
into woo territory but is there a
particular feeling that you associate
with checking those
boxes having those things in one person
and being with that person because
you've been
married now for 30 plus years am i
getting that right 33
33 years you did get it right so is
there a feeling
that you can identify a dominant feeling
and this may be a dead end that
or a general sense of being that you
associate with checking those boxes
i guess i'm just wondering if there's
some sort of holistic feedback that you
get kinesthetically or emotionally or
otherwise
that's a very deep question um
we do call it love
i've heard of this thing i've heard of
this i've heard of it too but it's
actually a very misleading word in the
following sense
i think people who stay married for a
long time
have a wide array of emotional
landscapes they live in
i think some of them
see their partners as their
soul mates
through most of their day even right
it's not just oh you know i think of my
wife when i go home and i see her and
i'm glad to see her it's that she in
case the other side he
they fell my soul
and day-to-day life it gets back to our
song about earlier it's not just oh
they're fun to be with it's that they
create an overarching sense of identity
of who they're part of who i am
by the way darwin didn't think about
that because he'd never experienced it
not just he hadn't been in love he never
crafted a life with another person
that's what real marriage is by the way
it's not it's not just that uh
it's convenient that there's economies
of scale because you don't have to you
know
you can go to costco more often if you
have kids and a wife so you can get a
lower unit price on the ketchup
that's not what it's about what's about
is a journey it's a journey that two
people share and you said looking for a
life partner it's not so fashionable
right most people aren't necessarily
looking for a life partner i'm not and i
by the way many negatives about a life
partner there are many positives about a
life partner it's complicated
but when you ask me what is the
i would ask your question this way
what suffuses you what are you
overwhelmed by
when you're with that person
for decades
and it's not every day and it's not
every night and it's not every vacation
right but the ideal is that
much of the time
you're filled with something the word
would be love you call love affection
whatever
but the reason i like your question is
that you know part of my book is asked
this looks at these decision makers
where they say things like
well i made the list of pluses and
minuses and it came out wrong
so i added some
pluses
or the poem i mentioned by piet hein who
was a scientist and a mathematician
who says you know when you can't make a
decision flip a coin
and when it's in the air you'll know
what you're rooting for you're written
for heads or tails and that'll say
that's what you really want that's
clever
that whole idea
of what you really want is such a
strange idea because what could you
really want
that goes above and beyond
the pluses and minuses i mean that's
just irrational
and a lot of smart people said not
exactly and by the way it doesn't mean
oh therefore you should follow your gut
follow your intuition
that can be very dangerous also cost you
a lot of money leads you to marry the
wrong person you have to be thoughtful
about this the alternatives aren't
use science or just follow your gut i
don't think
either one is the right way to think
about these kind of decisions
so it's it's both and not
either or it sounds like yeah for sure i
have a line in front of me that i love
which is from you so i'm not certainly
not going to take credit for it and this
may wind into
what we end up discussing i am going to
come back to the costco example that you
gave in the economies of scale
but what was once destiny is now a
decision
yeah i would love for us to unpack this
but i would like to
come back to the point i just raised
first
which you said very jokingly of course
because it'd be kind of ludicrous to
marry someone just to get a discount on
your equivalent of prime membership at
costco so you can buy you know two
gallons of ketchup for the price of one
gallon of ketchup but if we look back at
the historical record it wasn't so long
ago
that i would imagine most marriages were
marriages that did lend themselves maybe
more easily to pro and con lists right
they were political alliances they were
business agreements they were family
alliances and sharing of resources
things like that
and
i'm wondering if
if you
think
that
there's some degree
of
to what extent are we making ourselves
miserable by expecting to find happiness
in
one person or one person to check all of
these
boxes including romantic notions that
seem to have largely started in the
western world with troubadours and so on
i don't know if that's a coherent
question but since you have more
experience with these things than i do
i'd love to
hear you speak to that in any way
whatsoever
that's a deep question kind of a hard
one i think it's a great insight
that
a lot of marriages in the past were
either arranged
right by the parents
and
or
had ulterior motives
even if it was just to get the crops in
i mean we're joking about economies of
scale but economy scale were not
unimportant in most of human history you
had kids partly to help you slap the
hogs i mean and milk the cows
right and to take care of when you get
old these were
very pragmatic unromantic
ideas having said that
any
trip through western literature
you understand there's a little both
right you read shakespeare you read jane
austen jane austen's characters usually
are striving to make a advantageous
match
not a love match
but they also fall in love so that's one
of the reasons i think her books are so
compelling
they don't just want to be
pragmatic
but but it's a very deep question of
whether
what you should look for what you should
expect of marriage and and i think
hollywood misleads us a little bit
you know look across the room and
i've argued they're very few movies
that capture love right they're movies
that capture romantic attraction sexual
attraction
i'll give you an exception
my fair lady
not a very
pc or
you know politically correct movie in
modern times
but it's a fascinating portrait of how
henry higgins falls in love with the
lies of doolittle despite himself right
he doesn't want to fall in love he sees
his bachelorhood life as an ideal kind
of like darwin actually and yet
he finds himself falling in love and um
you know it's one of the most beautiful
love songs ever written when you think
how do you capture that feeling of
[Music]
real love not just attraction
he says i've grown accustomed to her
face
what a magnificent magnificent line
right
her smiles her frowns her ups or downs
their second nature to me now
like breathing out and breathing in
like that's an incredible portrait of
domestic life right
yeah
my point being that
art
actually
pays some attention to this thing that
evidently has been around for a long
time it's not just about
sexual attraction it's about love and
romantic attraction or whatever you want
to call that a partnership
symbiosis to make it really as
undramatic as possible maybe even less
romantic than uh
economies of scale at costco
but i think to come back to the nub
so what should you look for what should
you expect you know and is it worth it
is it worth some is it something you
should strive for
i'll just say what you know we could
talk about this with another five hours
but the one thing i would add
i don't like it when people say
you know you have to work at your
marriage
you have to work at it that's not the
way i think of my marriage
i work at crossword puzzles
i work at ditch digging i work at you
know
writing up my notes for my next podcast
but what you do have to do
is you have to treat your partner as a
partner
as opposed to somebody who you know
lives with you who's pleasant to have
his roommate
they're two different things and i think
in modern life we have not
we've taken away for a thousand reasons
the
responsibilities of marriage
and
and i think that's come at a cost right
and
it's made it harder for people to get
married if you look at the data it's
pretty obvious let's be uh scientific
for a minute
people are marrying later or not at all
it's changed
and does the appeal
comes back to the darwin point the
appeal of a long-term commitment
from the outside is mostly negative for
most people
i think certainly for most men
i don't know if women are different but
they seem to be it's not fashionable to
say that but i think they are
but men it's hard men struggle to stay
in a long-term relationship
and it's not as appealing to either side
it's pretty obvious
in the data so
what do you do
well tricky
could you say more about the
diminishing of the responsibilities of
marriage and what you mean by that
the part i like about you have to work
at your marriage is it it is hard
there are parts of my marriage that are
hard there's parts about having a good
marriage that are difficult that are
challenging
there's a great line from
andy lamott
she says
her name for god
not me
right and most of us
naturally see ourselves as
god center of the universe most
important thing
easy
and i think
one of the great advantages of marriage
is to remind you that it's not all about
you
and
you know some people find that appealing
and some people don't i think i took
this line out of the book but i have a
friend who said uh until you get married
his father told him this until you get
married you're an idiot
i feel that sometimes i think there's a
lot of truth to that and
living with another person is a
commitment
not as a contract very important
difference i talk about in the book it's
more of a covenant and less of a
contract
is really a powerful way to be alive
it's basically this is to enhance what i
said earlier about
what a real marriage is about it's not
about working at it oh let's have a
session where we talk about our you know
issues
it's about remembering because back to
what we said the very beginning this
conversation remembering things that are
very hard to remember that you're in
this together this other person has a
soul
a desire a flavor a preference
and
that's hard because you have yours and
you know what i like getting what i want
don't you
yeah we do most of us most of the time
and to figure out how to mesh your plans
with your partner's plans
and not just what we're doing on sunday
night because we can take turns and
we'll do italian tonight next week we'll
do chinese
but how to make a life together is um
really hard and beautiful and deeply
rewarding if it goes well and when it
doesn't go well it's horrible by the way
i don't want to romanticize it at all
right it's horrible
awful stultifying
degrading
it's bad so it's a high risk game and to
come back to your earlier question
for most human history it wasn't a
choice it was a destiny it wasn't a
decision
you got married you had to you felt that
way anyway it doesn't feel that way
anymore whole new world
all right so i have a number of
follow-up questions and i'm not going to
spend
the next hour on marriage so don't worry
but i do have one clarifying question
which is until you're married you're an
idiot are you in does that refer to
being an idiot in the sense of being
so ego-centric and self-referential that
you just don't have
the sort of lens or experience of the
world that is as broad and more complete
as someone who has decided to partner
with someone else
yeah
yeah okay
that's it exactly
it's not the normal kind of obviously it
is slightly different way
i've come to believe as i've gotten
older
that
a huge part of quote growing up
you know we like to joke
hey tim what do you do when you grow up
you know like like you still have room
to grow well i hope you do right we're
not all grown absolutely it's like
shalom right you're not whole you're not
grown up
one of the funniest things in life is
you look at the people older than you
and you think when i'm their age i'll
feel the way they do and you get to that
age and you don't
right you look at the seniors in high
school when you're in sophomore wow
they're so confident and they seem so at
ease
i can't wait till i'm a senior then
you're a senior it's like
they were all faking it every one of
them
right
and it's a great thing i think to admit
that i'm not grown up i haven't figured
it all out i haven't not mature fully
more mature maybe than i was before but
i'm not mature it's hard
so
a lot of what
to me
of a life well lived is about growing up
and marriage is one way to grow up not
the only way there are other ways to
grow up
religion meditation psychotherapy
marriage they're all about
self-awareness they're all if they're
done well they're all about recognizing
that you're part of a much bigger
picture than you feel like most of the
time
and i think that's really helpful and
incredibly satisfying when you sense it
it's great
so i'd like to ask a question that i
don't think has ever been asked before
in the history of podcasting which is
i would love for you to tell me more
about
life lessons from bill belichick and
also why you moved to israel and it
doesn't have to be in that order it
could be in the opposite order yeah
that's definitely never been asked
it's never been asked it's fantastic
so
i did something a little bit weird in
the book
i literally don't know if it's true i
think i admit it that i don't know if
it's true
and it's not surprising that we don't
know if it's true because bill belichick
doesn't like to tell secrets he keeps
them to himself
i guess nobody tells secrets because if
they did they wouldn't be secrets
anymore but bill belichick has a lot of
things that he keeps to himself
and maybe someday he'll write a book
about what he understands about football
should be interesting
but i think he understands something
about life whether it's
intentional or not he by the way was an
economics major i did not know i was an
undergraduate at wesleyan
and one of the things you learned from
economics is trade-offs and trade-offs
are really obvious
when you think about them but like many
things we're talking about this
conversation
they're hard to remember to think about
so
a lot of times we kind of ignore
trade-offs so we go through our lives
and what i argue bill belichick
understands
is that he's not that good
at drafting
future
nfl
successful players by the way bill
belichick is the coach of the new
england patriots a football team in the
national football league
which we should have mentioned so
belichick
each year gets to draft pick from the
crop of college players
a certain
set of players and i argue in the book
in this part i'm not sure it's true but
i think it's true a lot of times he will
trade away a draft choice to have more
draft choices lower down
later in the draft
and
and the reason i argue he does that so
this is all speculative it's kind of fun
but i think it's a good lesson for life
is that he wants to increase the
denominator when he's thinking about the
ratio of successful
picks
to total picks
he knows that he's not it's not a big
number so the bigger he makes the
denominator
he's going to get a few good players out
of the whole thing he can't predict in
advance who they necessarily are going
to be
this by the way is very similar to the
way some people invest yeah very similar
instead of picking winners
they pick an index fund they take all
the stocks because they say i can't
it's crazy
it's hard to believe but i think it's
mostly true
you can't on average you could do pretty
well but you can't necessarily pick out
in advance
which you're going to succeed you can
think about this in venture capital you
know you hope for one unit of every 10
investments one unicorn is extraordinary
most of the
investments are going to go broke
they're not going to make it literally
they're going to not going to cover
their costs ever and a few there will be
somewhat successful if you're lucky get
a couple home runs a unicorn a company
worth a billion dollars that'd be
amazing right one out of ten the crazy
thing is you don't know which one that's
a one out of ten so that's bizarre so i
think life is something like that and so
what i argue in the book and then we'll
get to why i moved to israel but what i
reckon the book is that
even though you can't always anticipate
what experiences are going to be like
and that's why one of the reasons that
cost benefit analysis is not that
helpful
in trying to figure out what to do in
these kind of situations
try lots of stuff and if you're lucky
some of those things will be things you
can
change you can so belichick if he
doesn't the player doesn't work out he
cuts them he doesn't sign them
i think every year for the last i don't
know 17 19 on how many years it is he
has signed a player who was not drafted
and i think he loves it i'm feeling it's
a little bit of a
of a seductive thing for him but he
almost always finds a player who uh no
one else wanted no one thought was worth
picking
and finds out that they can contribute
and he finds that out as the punch line
to the experience of working with them
and that's life
life a lot of the things that we try to
figure out am i going to like that not
like it
we we try to imagine reasonably what
it's going to be like we really can't
know what it's going to be like until
we're in it
and so you want to be in a lot of things
as long as they're not too high costs to
get out of because if they're high costs
then there's the trade-offs are more
serious
so
that's the bell check story
all right
so from bill belichick i recommend
everybody do a deep dive on bill
belichick and interesting man
fascinating and i do not follow football
to be clear so for me to say that take
something
absolutely fascinating
bill also has done quite a bit of
reading on stoic philosophy in the
stoics or
just all around a very very very
interesting guy
so we'll bookmark that for other people
tim when you get him on your podcast yes
would you encourage him to come online
he's going to come on yours before mine
but i really want to talk to him i will
i will absolutely yes if i'm if i manage
so
bill can be the white whale for both of
us if i get him first
then i will i will certainly recommend
that he he go on to your show
thank you
you're welcome so let's go to israel and
i'm going to attempt to tie a few things
together once we get into
the midst of of you
exploring this or explaining this but
why why move to israel
so i could offer this job to be
presidents college i'm jewish i've
always liked israel i've been here a
dozen times before i actually lived here
as a teenager when my dad's company sent
him here to look at an israeli company
as a possible
partner merger
or acquisition so i like israel it's
nice great place to visit i've always
enjoyed it
i care about it i think it's important i
think it's great that the jewish people
have a state
full stop
but i had no interest in moving here
it's a crazy idea
but i got offered this job and
the job is leading this college that has
a core curriculum in greek philosophy
jewish thought the koran the new
testament shakespeare
western history
and then you could either major in two
things when i got here down three but
philosophy and jewish thought are middle
eastern and islamic studies and learn
arabic that's that's the whole place and
i thought that's nice i'm glad it still
has a college like that it's a good
thing
but i'm not interested in working for
him of course that'd be a crazy idea but
the more i thought about it they weren't
realized that
if you listen to econ talk you find out
that i'm increasingly interested in
questions of what is the life well lived
and we've been having that conversation
for the last hour and a bit actually it
not explicitly but that's really what
we're talking about what is the life
well lived how do we flourish as human
beings
so that's at the center of the
intellectual mission of this college
and also to turn out leaders who will go
on to have a impact on the country which
i like and think that's a good thing
and i care a lot about education and
the bottle of education we represent
here is small seminars of people
exploring great texts together
respectfully in open inquiry
so like how could i say no and the only
answer really was if my wife didn't want
to come i would we wouldn't come coming
back to earlier conversation but she
thought it would be a great adventure
and so we jumped
we sold our house we put our stuff in
storage to be shipped here when we found
a place to live and uh we moved to
israel
and it's
it's drinking from a fire hose it's
it's uh you know people say to me so
how's it going i'm sure uh you settling
in
no we're not settling in
we are foreigners we're immigrants and
we're living in the middle east where
we've never lived before it's a jewish
state but it's in the middle east it's
culturally different than many places
where lots of jews live
so it's fascinating it's an incredible
life experience and the work part is
amazing uh and it's
you know an adventure incredible
adventure
so that is a big move
seems like a big decision
and
i would love to know if you are open to
just sharing the story of how you
pitched that to your wife what did that
conversation look like
i could tell you a little bit about it
it was actually it was funny it's very
vivid to me because it was the middle of
covid
and
most sundays during covid we spent uh
walking along the potomac river we had
to be outside often it was miserably hot
as it is outside the potomac river on in
july and august
june even and sometimes september and
you know anyway it's warm in dc area
but a vivid member was just walking
along and talking about whether we we
did something similar to what darwin
obviously i don't mean to make too much
fun of cost benefit obviously we spent
some time thinking about is this going
to be
fun are we gonna like it but that wasn't
the only thing in the calculus you know
we have friends here
but we have friends where we've been
living for 18 years and we miss them
our children are spread out all over the
world i have a
daughter in london a son in california a
son in maryland we have a son and we
have a son in australia
i said i i hate that we we have children
in all those places so one argument was
well israel's far from all them but so
is wherever we live so it's okay and um
we spent a pretty serious amount of time
talking about
the purpose
of
this job
you know my wife was uh
in america was a high school
math teacher fabulous math teacher but
she was thinking about doing something
different so for her this was going to
be a transition time anyway so we
focused on whether
we would like this job and by we it was
literally we in the sense that
my wife had been an administrator as
well and
as it turns out
most of the things that
she was challenged by as a minister i'm
challenged by his administrator too
people are kind of similar
you know there's issues of management
and getting along with other folks and
ego and normal human interaction so
she's an incredible advisor for me on
this in this job she's she's like
my
right-hand person obviously
and she cares about this mission if she
didn't i don't think we would have done
it if she didn't care about education
and this kind of purpose i think she
thought it would be good for me
i think she saw that
she thought it was a chance for her to
explore a bunch of new things
but really it was is this what we're
meant to do
you know you can put a divine
twist on that but it doesn't i think a
lot of non-religious people
have a similar feeling about their life
right
is this what i'm called to
right is this what why i'm here
and we both felt that this was part of
why we were here is to take this
opportunity if we could do it well you
know if we could if we could be
successful at it
and so um
you know that verdict isn't in yet but
it's it's been an amazing first year
so i know
quite a few uh jewish friends uh some of
which have ended up moving to israel or
figuring out ways from the us or within
israel to contribute to israel how much
of it was a
contribution to
israel and its people
versus the particulars of
this college its curriculum its approach
to education
it was definitely both this had been in
say bosnia i don't think i would have
done it
you know the chance to lead a small
liberal arts college in bosnia wouldn't
appeal to me i may be kind of
interesting but the the downside would
have been significantly this would be
large enough that i would have said no
to it
so a lot of it was the formers a chance
to contribute a chance to
you know jews have been talking about
coming back to jerusalem for 2000 years
since the second temple was destroyed
and the fact that in my lifetime
we have a jewish state
is
amazing and i am very proud and
it's exhilarating to me to be part of it
you know it
there's so many
day-to-day moments here
it's it's hard to explain
what it's like to live here in the
following sense
if you open up
an israeli newspaper on any any day
there's almost the same headlines it's
almost the same headlines every day
terrorist attacks worded in such such
place iran heats up
new government coming elections
next month and then my favorite 14 year
old girl finds roman coin in
in casaria that shows uh existence of
so-and-so's
herod's rule in whatever time so
everything here matters
it's so consequential to to be here
as part of the jewish experience so
that's that's that's a lot of it for me
it's pretty fun too by the way i don't
mean to downgrade the fun part it's
jerusalem's an amazing city it's got
much more interesting as a place to live
in the last 20 years it's uh it's very
nice
yeah i've i've noticed have you been
here
have you been here i have i actually
went to israel for the first and only
time to
join
a training
i was auditing but in this case it was a
training for mdma assisted psychotherapy
which was
funded in part by the equivalent of the
ministry of health maybe it's called the
ministry of health and israel
first in terms of government funding
exactly i was that was coming next so
the tip of your tongue right it was just
there
and we
we engaged in the training on i don't
think it would be called a kibbutz but
it was a communal living environment
which was
half jewish and half
muslim and
that certainly made it very very very
interesting and the feeling certainly is
in israel
and i suppose in
in a number of places in the middle east
that
almost everything is or seems
consequential
and it makes me think i'm not going to
get the attribution right i think it was
joseph campbell but it may have been
victor frankl who said what we're
seeking is not the meaning of life but a
feeling of being alive and i think you
get that
it's hard to escape that when you're in
a place like israel it seems so behind
me
which if you're watching this on youtube
you can see is a shade
if we raise that shade and you stood at
that window
you were about two miles from the old
city of jerusalem and the temple mount
where you can see the dome of the rock
a great
muslim shrine and the temple mount is
the great jewish shrine where the
western wall is the kotel as it's called
in hebrew
and
sometimes i look down on that for my i
can see it from my office as soon as i
look down on that and i have moved
because it's
it's bizarre it's so small it is so
small and it feels like it's the center
of the universe sometimes
meaning everything is over
dramatized here you say everything
matters everything seems consequential
um
the poet said that jerusalem is a
port city on the sea of
eternity so you have this
credible spiritual
center here for the three great
abrahamic religions
you have the political tensions
that rivet the world
and uh you also have modern life and
great great food and music and it's
really small
not just the old city i mean the old
city is tiny israel is really small if
you look at israel on a map
you can barely pick it out most of the
time and it gets so much attention it's
a little bit weird
leave it at that
walking through the old city is one of
the most intense
i've done it twice one of the more
intense experiences i've ever had in my
life it's the
uh again i'll i guess i'll keep it keep
it simple but the the sort of tension
and attention in the air is so palpable
i don't want to get too mystical but it
could just be kinesthetic it is
very
very perceptible although i'll put it to
that it's a weird physical setting
it's it's almost all paved
it's this weird cobblestone ancient
stone
the stones there's stones
over here in the old city that are
that were carved out
2 000 years ago to build
things and they're still there
and there's walls from 600 years ago
from crusader times and
it's
you know you go to england it's old
england makes the united states look
brand new you know we have history of
the united states cup
1776 you go to england it's like we have
no history
you go to come to israel it's like
england has no history
so i wanted to
maybe awkwardly you can tell me after i
asked the question bring back
what was once destiny is now a decision
and i may be putting this in the wrong
context but one thing that i feel i've
observed with my audience over the last
say year or two in particular
is a certain degree of growing apathy
but i think the apathy is derived from
many different
factors one of which is just decision
fatigue and overwhelm
which is where i do think numeracy and
other basic capabilities
come in very very handy so that you're
not just lost in the rapids of noise
but my question related to all of that
is
to what extent this is going to be
strange wording so
it's deliberate but it might seem odd
to what extent has
religion
been an advantage for you
in the sense
that it provides rules and maybe some
automaticity to certain aspects of life
i'm not religious but there are
definitely times when i envy those who
are and i would just be curious to hear
any and all thoughts on that
can we talk about the first part first
about the decision fatigue
so i've been very lucky i
i got covered about a month ago for the
first time
it was really unpleasant i was in bed
for three days
couldn't have had any energy
and i was tired for another 10 days
beat just beat but i had a lucky i
didn't end up on a ventilator i didn't
die it's like it was a bad flu in the
omicron phase here
but for two years especially the night
when i was in the united states before i
came here
i had a
i think for most of us it was a very
unusual life experience
it was a little bit not a lot but a
little bit like war
so war if you think back say the bombing
of of london
you think about it every night sirens go
off you go down underground in london or
you go to some place of shelter and you
come back out
if you're lucky your house is still
there if you're not lucky if your house
is gone and maybe somebody died who you
cared about and can you imagine that
night after night after night and after
a while you'd say
you know it's really hard but the
hardest part of it is i don't know when
it's going to end
if you just tell me when it's going to
end
i can handle it give me the arrival date
what's the eta
of the of peace and of course
most wars
they think oh it'll be over in a week
you know civil war it'll be over in a
week two weeks month
most wars drag on
as hard as kov it was and again it's
embarrassing to compare it to or can you
imagine what it was like to to be in
london or berlin
or japan
not in the united states because the
united states was pretty protected but
in these countries where
day in day out your loved ones were
dying
and you don't know when it's going to
end
and you more than anything else you just
want what do you want just give me a
normal day where i don't have to be
afraid not to hear worried that
someone's going to die so covet gave us
a tiny
thank god relatively much smaller taste
of that and for most people
i thought for me it was incredibly hard
it was like when am i going to be able
to fill in the blank
right what am i going to have i just
want a normal i want to go out to a bar
and see some friends and have a drink or
go to a party or better get go to a
wedding or
go even go to a funeral right there are
people who miss funerals who miss
weddings who missed wonderful life
events and couldn't participate
and so
i think
that really wore us down or a lot of us
down right it's very very
demoralizing there's some wonderful
things about it you faced your mortality
most of us i think had to recommend the
fact
when i got my vaccine finally it's like
oh
now i i felt like superman
oh i forgot i'm still gonna die that
stinks doesn't it right but it forced
you to remember that that you're gonna
die
you might die soon from covet
in a hospital on a ventilator
horrible way to go
and if you're lucky you don't get it but
you're still going to die and i think
for a lot of those two things when's it
going to end and i am mortal and i most
of us again coming back to our theme
of things you don't want to think about
are easy not to think about the fact
that we're going to die is
not pleasant let's just push that one
off so i thought that those two things
really wore us down so what does that
have to do with religion
i think
religion's really interesting obviously
it's a
it's a fascinating part of of human
experience
both glorious and inglorious
i think people who aren't religious
think it makes life easy in the way that
you suggested the automaticity ah things
are taken care of and there is a piece
of that by the way
i keep the jewish sabbath so if you say
to me i've got tickets to see
paul mccartney who i don't particularly
like but he's i'd like to go see him not
my favorite musician but he's at the
meadowlands with bruce springsteen is
going gonna show up which happened
recently i don't i don't know if it's a
friday night or not but if you said you
want to go i'd say oh yeah i want to go
oh it's friday no i can't go
so
for me
a lot of it does rule out
certain decisions that that would
otherwise you'd have to wait there's no
doubt about that
but i think a lot of people think that a
religious life is one that's free of
doubt and is a bunch of angels sitting
around singing
strumming guitars you know
a bunch of good martin guitars singing
some
kumbayas aren't it's really not the main
thing about religion that's attractive
to me and maybe to other people
because i have plenty of doubts by the
way and i think most most religious
people in the modern era
struggle with faith i think it's a
i know i shouldn't say most many do
for me it comes back to what we talked
about earlier i didn't write about this
in the book but
it gives life a certain
texture and part of what i'm trying to
say in that book in wild problems
is that there's more to life than
the emotional ups and downs and what we
call fun or happiness
and there's a certain texture to life
that comes safe from being married or
being a parent
or moving to israel
or having a certain career maybe in a
profession that makes you feel
full
and and yourself
and that texture
is to me a lot of what religious life is
about
it's the
again not that different from many of
the things we've been talking about
there are friday nights where i wish i
could do something i choose not to do
more globally
but the overall impact
has a
effect on how i see myself
and how i go through the world
that i find
meaningful
i don't think it's accessible to
everyone
for me in my experience a little bit
like music
some people are tone deaf
and they cannot enjoy music the way
a great musician can or even a mediocre
musician
and other people have a great ear
and
all that music makes their hearts sing
all the time and they live in a
different world than the rest of us and
i think there's a whole continuum of
both music and religious
slash spiritual
practice
that
we inhabit
that is personal that is person specific
it's like i give you my favorite novel
and you're gonna love this
and it didn't speak to me
that's what happens and there's certain
religious experiences or spiritual
experiences spiritual practices
that don't speak to certain people
because they're just not hardwired that
way i think i don't know
if i may well segue to a rather motley
assortment of questions that may not
have any thematic through line
whatsoever
if that's okay
sure actually they do have they do have
a through line which is my personal
curiosity
so the
the first and again i'm i'm trying to
craft novel segues here so we're going
to go from nasim talib to
the talmud
okay
not related so the first uh is related
to nassim so i i have not had any
contact with him in many years but we
had two
meals
long long long long long time ago he
goes on very few podcasts
he's been on yours several times
and
i'm looking at another
bit from
bit meaning portion of a transcript from
your conversation with tyler cowan and
i'm just going to read this
line here i get a lot of flack for
interviewing nassim taleb because his
online persona seems to be different
from mine i'll say it judiciously i've
learned an immense amount from him i
would just love to hear
you speak more to what you have learned
from him or his writing or gleaned from
him or his writing
i've been meaning to write an essay on
this for a while because
i've i've never systematically thought
about it occasionally you know someone
will say oh he's so he's so annoying or
i don't like him or
and why do you have him on your show
it's it's against your
philosophy of
i try to have civil conversations with
people i disagree with and i have very
simple conversations with the sin by the
way but
he wrote a book his first book was
called fooled by randomness
great book
it's a fabulous book a lot of people's
reaction to that book was oh there's
nothing new in there
and i could argue i guess i'm you know
as a phd in economics i take a bunch of
statistics what's called econometrics
the application of statistics economic
problems you can argue i do everything
in there but i didn't know it in my
bones and that's a lot of what we're
talking about today which is
how do you pay attention
and he taught me how to pay attention to
some things out in the real world that i
was totally
unaware of in the moment if you said to
me later did you realize i'll take one
here's an easy one
if you go to great falls national park
which is a fantastic park very maybe one
of the finest
nature experiences you can have very
very close to a large metropolitan area
just outside washington dc there's a
side in virginia and a side of maryland
both sides are interesting with great
hikes along the potomac river there
there's incredible waterfalls and
turbulent waters very very beautiful
place
there's a great sign fantastic sign
it's not really a sign it's a stick
on the virginia side
and it's you have to look up and you
look up and it says this is the high
water mark of the potomac river so
you're you're
i don't know 150 feet above the potomac
river already
and then there's this post in the ground
that goes up another 12 and a half
whatever it is 15 feet and that's the
high water mark of the potomac river and
it's
hard to imagine that it could flood to
that level but evidently it has let's
take that as as a fact
so if you're building a house
in virginia
near the potomac river how high should
you build it and the answer some people
would actually argue is that if you
build it higher than that sign
you're safe
and you'd be wrong
because the past is not necessarily a
good predictor of the future
and we all know that that's not that's
the most trivial
obvious thing and yet
to take another a financial example
oh well you know the s p 500 there's
never been a 10-year period with a
negative return i don't even remember
now whatever it is take take all the
different decades and i don't mean 1920
to 1930 1930 to 1940 i mean 21 to 31 22
to 32 1923 to 1933
and you could look at all of those and
you could take the worst 10-year period
and you'd say okay
so i'm
like i'm right now i'm 67. in 10 years
i'll be 77
so if i invest all my money in the s p
500 and don't touch it for a decade
what's the worst thing that could happen
well the answer is something worse than
this happened before possibly and that
that is a possibility is so hard to
remember for most people
because really really smart people make
that mistake all the time
so that's a simple thing that i've
learned from him that's not that's not
like dramatic i'll give you one more
one of my favorites as an economist
so he has a book called skid in the game
skiing in the game is like the bread and
butter of economics it's the whole idea
that incentives matter
so skin in the game means if
i bear
the costs of mistakes
and i enjoy the fruits of my good
decisions that skin in the game right
that's great and a fancy name
for economists when they talk about this
is incentives are aligned
but it means gets again in the game
and you know milton friedman like to say
that capitalism is a profit and loss
system
the profit encourages risk taking the
loss encourages prudence
so profit and loss encourage prudent
risk-taking not reckless risk-taking if
you bail out losers
you have taken away the loss and you get
imprudent risk-taking it's a bad idea
so economists understand this we get it
but talib taught me something i hadn't
understood or appreciated about skin in
the game which is fascinating
which is that
if
let's say you don't pay attention to the
fact that you've got skin in the game
you're oblivious economists like to
argue people are rational they take
account of their gains they take account
of their losses that's why they're
prudent risk takers if there's profit
and loss
but what talent points out is that
if you're really bad at something
and you ignore
the risks
you get taken out of the game you're not
in the pool anymore
and so even if you're not paying
attention skin in the game makes a
difference because it weeds out
say
gamblers who are
imprudent risk takers unless you bail
them out if you take out the skin in the
game but i've always said economists
thought oh yeah you look at it you take
into account the effect every economist
would tell you this
but he made me appreciate that even if
you're not paying attention
as long as you don't bail out losers
they'll be weeded out of the process
nice point cool
i've enjoyed his writing i i first read
actually the the black swan
and then
went back to fool by randomists also
read anti-fragile very popular among
some former well at the time current
military intelligence guys
and
i was introduced actually to his work
first by a a friend of mine an
incredible
tech innovator named matt mullenweg and
then
later
had anti-fragile
recommended to me by military folks
interesting just as a side note i was
introduced to him by late seth roberts i
don't know if he ever knew seth roberts
great guy no relation no relation but
the first time i ever met nassim in
person i think it was the day after
lehman had collapsed it was quite a time
to have a conversation
uh so let's go from
from lehman brothers to the talmud am i
saying that word remotely correctly
all right exactly correctly okay well
sorry if you're an american you're
saying it correctly right an israeli
would say talmud
so i have
a quote here
that
i'll put into context so this is
on on a site called priceonomics
and here it goes so some of his
commentary and then we have a quote that
i would love for you to expand on
explaining complex economic ideas can be
a sisyphean task a fact that roberts
acknowledges quote of course it's
frustrating sometimes it's very
depressing end quote he says but he's
philosophical about what person can do
and here we go i follow what the talmud
says about this
it is not up to you to finish the work
but neither are you free to desist from
it
so that last line
is
what i would love to hear more about
it's kind of embarrassing to talk about
it actually no one's ever asked me to
expound on that
and it
forces me to think about coming full
circle to our earlier
first thing we talked about which was my
dad
and i think many of us
are raised to think that we have
obligations we have things we're
supposed to do
things are supposed to pick up
tasks
and i've always felt that to some extent
i don't know
how much of its genetic how much of its
cultural the way i was raised
so that idea that you're not free to
desist from it
again i don't you can think think of it
as a religious statement but i don't
think it's most people there are plenty
of non-religious people who have that
same feeling now sometimes they're
called type a
i should be careful type a people who
need to do stuff
it's not quite the same not quite the
same but
but the idea that you're supposed to do
something of consequence that that
you're not just here to enjoy yourself
is a burden or blessing i've always
somewhat felt i don't want to be
arrogant about it i think you can easily
take it as pretentious
it's interesting you know i had a
conversation with mentioned tyler cowan
earlier we did this episode on how we
read
our reading habits
and it was really fun to talk tyler's
an unimaginable amount um it really is
unimaginable he actually i think
understands some of it which is even
better and remember some of it which is
even better
but series i have a lot of respect for
tyler he's a he's a great great thinker
and
polymath and somebody wrote me a
fascinating email they said you know i
read what you wrote about reading and
one of the things i like to say is that
and if you read a book a week
which is a lot
you can read about 50 books a year and
if you're you're around for about 50
years of reading
maybe a little more but it's uh 2 500
books that's it that's it
yeah there's a hundred thousand books
i think but maybe more i don't remember
how many books are published a year
maybe it's a million it's a big number
yeah at least a hundred thousand and i
get to read 2500 in a lifetime so
i always say pick them carefully
which i don't always live by i read a
lot of books that are either
not always so interesting and i i've
gotten better at stopping when i was
younger i couldn't put down a book
without finishing it was a moral
imperative terrible habit i got over
that thank goodness but you have a
limited number of books to read and this
listener said to me how do you justify
watching a baseball game
you know and you could argue the same
thing when you think about the talmud
it's not up to you to finish the work
but it's you're not free to desist from
it and while you're watching baseball
you're
kind of desisting from it so if you
think of your life as having purpose and
you're supposed to do stuff and
accomplish right which i again i think i
was
both hardwired and and culturally pushed
to do by my by my parents
and i singled out my dad because he's
the one who drove it home for me much
more than my mom
who gave me other things but not this
or cursed me
again it's a blessing or burden i don't
know
i like to think of it as a blessing
but how do you justify like fooling
around you know doing nothing
playing your 40th game of chess in a row
because you can't sleep and you're
compulsively
watching your score on chess.com dwindle
steadily through the night
i have a smart sign that says you know
when you lose two in a row maybe stop
playing
yeah
he thinks the goal is to win yeah the
goal is not to win the goal is to
distract yourself it's terrible i play
too much yes right i think i do but
frivolous things
and certainly there is by the way a
strong impulse in judaism and i assume
other religions
not to waste time it's a precious thing
and you should be studying learning
growing contributing doing good deeds
and yet watching a baseball game how do
you justify it so
you know i wrote it back and said
part of the reason i enjoy the
occasional baseball game which i don't
watch much from israel because the time
side doesn't work so well
part of the reason i like watching
sports is that there's drama yeah it's
about a human being and a set of human
beings put in a cauldron of expectations
and pressure
and to watch them emerge successfully
or to be
to fail is is is like watching a great
drama
that's one argument the second is that
because you need some down time it's
okay
[Music]
your head's going to explode otherwise
but i do think
for myself whether it's
for whatever reason and i think for many
people we feel we have to we can't
desist from it we have a job to do
by the way it's not all i mean i have to
build a
house for a homeless person sometimes
it's just i have to grow
i'd say that's even more of a it's not
exactly the top it's not the talmud
quote but it's a different
impulse that that's not totally
unrelated which is
don't just stagnate you know which is a
weird attitude in a finite life right
yeah i want to just ask a handful of
last questions and the next one is
related to prayer and this may be
dated i don't think it's too dated but
i'm reading a quote i think it's quote
from you which is i'm trying to write a
book on prayer for people who struggle
with prayer and i think most people do
at least the ones i know and then it
goes on to talk about other potential
books on forgiveness and so on
i would
love to know
what prayer
means to you
and if such a book would be for
religious people or if
a
version of prayer would be
made
available through such writing to people
who do not consider themselves religious
definitely the most personal question
anyone's ever asked me
tim but since we've been talking now for
almost two hours i feel like we're very
close
now i'm teasing of course but let me try
to answer that i am trying to write a
book on prayer and since
i became president of shalom college i
was lucky to finish wild problems i
haven't made any progress on that prayer
book since i got to israel it's kind of
ironic
the holy land
but i think for people who aren't
religious and by the way i was not
religious my whole life so i had a
a part of my life where i was not
praying regularly and where i was not
keeping the jewish sabbath where i was
eating lobster and pork and enjoying it
immensely
and i think every not everyone it comes
back a little bit to the comment i made
earlier about being tone deaf but
most people i think
can experience the transcendent
or the a word that i find very difficult
to think about but i love the word it's
imminent not
meaning soon but sort of embodied in you
imminent i am
a-n-e-n-t
and in the book that i'm working on uh
someday maybe
i talk about the handful of times when
i've come into contact with that and i'm
sure you have two
example i use is i'm in california
we've taken the family my wife and i've
taken the kids to see it the shakespeare
production outside in uh in santa cruz
which is just really fun you're in these
redwoods and uh it's it's just it's
lovely
it's been a long day we've had a good
time as a family and
we're driving back and i think
everybody's asleep in the car except me
we're driving back to palo alto and um
[Music]
i realize that to my left
it is such a dark night for some reason
and there's so little light pollution
that the stars are as vivid as they are
say in yosemite or
the negev the desert here in israel
these are the two places i've seen the
best stars of my life
and
they're luminous they're not just like
white dots they're they're luminous
and
you can see them all the way down to the
ocean right i'm on the coast so i'm
coming up i'm driving north on the coast
and i can see
constellations and stars
at the horizon
i mean it gives me goosebumps to talk
about it yeah i don't remember if i woke
everybody up or even stopped the car i i
just
it was a little bit dangerous i'm you
know i roll down the window to get
better sight and i remember just i kept
turning my head and um
i felt connected to something now was i
really connected to something am i
imagining it
i don't really care actually i hope it's
true that there's something greater than
just
nature and the material and and
my
animal self
but there might not be but i do feel it
sometimes and i think most of us have
moments like that
alan lightman the physicist
has a wonderful book on this he's an
atheist
but he talks about lying in a boat
looking up at the stars and how
you feel something and it bothers him as
a physicist and he writes about this
discomfort that he feels something
transcendent there something bigger than
himself
so you can feel it out in nature
i have felt it many times not enough but
many times in
random encounters with human beings
under duress
i'm sure you have too where you
you meet someone who's having a very bad
time
and you interact with them in a way that
is not normal you don't usually have
people
sharing incredibly personal things but
they do they need to share it and they
pour out their heart to you and and
you're there for them
and you know one of these moments for me
is
this person said you don't want to hear
this do you
and i said no i do
i do and the truth is i didn't want to
hear it but i did i was compelled
literally compelled i wasn't gonna go
anywhere i wasn't gonna
part of me want to run away because it
was so painful it was such a heartache
this person was sharing
somebody i didn't know very well and
those moments those handful of times in
in my life as a human being
where i've encountered another human
being either under duress or in joy it's
also a joy
you know the birth of my children shared
when i wasn't you know privileged to be
in the
in the room with my wife when we when
she asked when we gave birth she did
most of the work pretty sure
when she gave birth those moments are
not just like oh that was really fun
even more trivial ones you know
great great musical performances
you know i've written about this um
you know watching next to normal and i
think her name is rachel bay jones
pour out her self in front of
2000 strangers
and expose herself emotionally
as the character in that play and do it
in a way that isn't just like i'm
actually you don't feel like she's
acting at all you feel like she's
sharing a piece of her human giving you
access to something that's in you too
those moments
they're
they're transcendent they're part of
something bigger than ourselves so
that's what i think of
with prayer i think a prayer is
accessing those or trying to access
those more frequently
and for me it's tied in with a belief in
god or a hope of god's being there and
listening but i think for non-religious
people there's something there even when
it's not
religious it's spiritual whatever you
want to call it
yeah thank you for that explanation in
those examples i agree with you on the
access
to such things even if you do not
identify as a theist in any way i
certainly i certainly would agree with
that russ i appreciate you as a thinker
i appreciate you as a teacher
i've enjoyed this conversation i'm not
in a rush to close it but
also just being cognizant of time and
all other things is there anything else
that you would like to add any stories
you'd like to tell any requests of the
audience anything before we wrap up
i want to ask you a question
yes please
you don't have to answer it of course
you can edit it out because it's your
show
fire away
you know we've been talking about
stepping outside yourself it's been a
sort of sub theme of this conversation
as an example of the life well lived
and
you are a very successful person
in multiple dimensions
you have an impact on the world
through the research you've been funding
i know about that because i keep an eye
on you
your podcast is phenomenally successful
your books are phenomenally successful
you're charismatic you're charming
how do you keep your head screwed on
straight is it a challenge
we've been talking about this right you
should be following yourself it would be
totally normal for you to be completely
full of yourself
do you have anything you do
to try to keep your feet on the ground
and to stay sane i don't think it's so
healthy by the way right most of us
aspire
to a you know i wish my podcast audience
were bigger i wish it was more like tim
ferriss's i wish my book sold work like
tim ferriss's you're who we want to be
and yet you know what it's like it's not
that easy it's not and after a while
some of the thrill gets
gets a little old how do you say
uh grown up
thank you for
saying all that and for the question uh
i'll mention a few things the the first
is that and i'm not proud of this but i
am my
own
let's just say best critic or worst
enemy depending on
the day depending on the
impact that it has on me this being my
inner voices
on my psychology and emotional state and
so on but
i do think that as a perfectionist
most of what i do
is never
up to my standards whatever those
imaginary standards might be or as
unreachable as they might be so i think
that's
that's one
i've certainly
been told and i'm sure this is a tribute
to someone else originally but a
older
friend of mine said long time ago he
said you're never as good as they say
you are and you're never as bad as they
say you are
and i've
often
reminded myself of that i think that i i
also
at least through the podcast and
sometimes through the books even though
i haven't written a what i would
consider a proper book in quite some
time i would say 10 years actually
i try to broadcast the mistakes and the
failures i try to
serve up
equal portions of success stories and
also
misguided
side alleys that end in disaster
sure
so that i'm not creating a highlight
reel for people it's very difficult not
to do that especially i think in some
cases in the podcast
when
what gets broadcast and you know this
too is is a relatively small piece or
can be a very relatively small piece of
the entire operation and what goes into
it and the survivorship bias i mean if
you really have a terrible interview it
doesn't get shared or it gets edited so
tremendously that it's it's sort of
frank and spliced into something that
sounds a lot better than what happened
in reality
uh and i also have a very lucky and this
is by certainly by luck and
[Music]
somewhat by design on top of that
i have
great friends who
will call me on my [ __ ] and
will certainly
stress test any position
that i hold really strongly
and i'm very fortunate you know i
mentioned one person matt mullenweg he's
certainly one of those people he's
excellent at seeing things from
different perspectives and he will
even as devil's advocate even if he
doesn't have a dog in the fight with a
particular position he will force me
through ruthless cross-examination to
look very closely at perspectives i
might be ignoring
alternative explanations i might be
conveniently dismissing
and
those are the first handful of things
that that come to mind for me i would
also say that just by virtue of the
and certainly you have been doing this
so much longer than i have and have been
an inspiration to me in this podcast in
so many ways
when you interview people who are
exceptional at what they do all the time
it highlights how much
i'll speak for myself i personally do
not know and how many capacities i
either will never have or have not
developed
that
the older i get the more i realize how
incredibly little we understand to any
extent
it's actually very exciting to me
so those are those are a few things that
come to mind
for me
i like that observation about humility
because
i feel big a podcast host has made me
more humble
and i've had some success not like yours
right but i'm doing okay you're doing
you're doing okay yeah and in theory you
should just be in arrogant putts
and you might be tim i don't know you're
well i try not to be
definitely good goal
and for me
it's not just
i decided a long time ago
that i wanted to be empathetic
to my guests that i would make a better
show
it would be more
it's the right thing to do
and i thought it would make a better
show
and that was a very costly decision
because it forced me to reevaluate a lot
of things that i
had believed or held as dogma
and i haven't changed so much but i have
changed some
and one of the things have changed is as
you say you're forced to recognize your
own limitations i like to joke
that each week i get to interview a
person smarter than i am and ask them
dumb questions
but it's really the truth and it has
made me much smarter
as well as reminding me how little i
know and since we talked earlier about
now subdictors talib and one of my
favorite
quotes from him is the
he cites it as a venetian proverb
the farther from shore
the deeper the ocean
and
you know the more you learn the more you
realize how deep the water is she is a
long way to go yeah long way to go yeah
it really is so
so far to go and
i want to mention
just for people who may not identify as
religious in any way you mentioned the
and am i getting this right the negev
desert yeah yeah
if you have not had a transcendent
experience
and
i'll put aside defining that term for
now but if
if you are
curious about the types of experiences
that
that russ you were describing if you go
to the negev
do it with a tour it is a desert after
all
or have a tour guide at least
and sit there quietly which i did
with my girlfriend for about an hour
there is something
very
i mean the word that comes to mind is
bizarre but there is a feeling there
that i have not experienced anywhere
else and i can't put it into words and
nor do i really want to inflict the
violence of language on the
feeling but i will just say there's a
lot out there
for people to explore so i encourage
them to explore
and
russ you i've tracked your work for for
quite a long time
i've enjoyed a lot of your writing
including how adam smith can change your
life
you have a very wide spectrum of subject
matter that you explore
wild problems a guide to the decisions
that define us
is
the latest and newest which i'm very
excited about
and
i said it before i'll say it again i
really appreciate you and value you as a
as a thinker and as a teacher i think
you offer tremendous service to people
with econ talk for those who have not
heard econ talk go check it out there
are so many
fantastically
nuanced
and rich conversations to choose from
certainly i would would recommend people
take a look
and
that is a long way of saying thank you
thank you for doing what you do thank
you tim it's a treat to talk to you
look forward to doing in person sometime
as a person who aspires to perfection
you would be a great student at shalom
college you need to work on your hebrew
i do my classes are taught in hebrew so
um
something to look forward to
we'll see you later
something like that
yeah there we go well done i've got a
few words here and there so i'll work
out i'll work on my hebrew always always
open to learning new languages
and to everybody listening
certainly check out wild problems a
guide to the decisions that define us
you can find all things russ roberts
roberts.info on twitter at econ
and until next time please be a little
kinder than you think is necessary
look outside yourself
if you really
want to solve some of the problems that
you can't solve focusing within yourself
and thank you for tuning in
you